Alice were here at the launch at the
London Film Festival you've got your
film sightseers here which is shockingly
funny what can people expect from it
it's you can expect horror laughs maybe
surprising little little bit of sadness
and emotion
hopefully it's a dark comedy about a
couple you go on a road trip on a first
holiday together to see if they're going
to get along and unfortunately there's
quite dark
consequences to to the annoyances that
they feel on holiday which we all we all
feel when we're on holiday we get
annoyed with people but we don't usually
do what Chris and Tina do on this
particular holiday are you not only star
in the film but you also co-wrote it as
well didn't you with your other co-star
in the film now why did the idea come
from
well we quite often say that it came
from our parents and because we used to
go on lots of family holidays when
mutually you know we both grew up in the
Midlands and we started chatting about
that and how we used to go on long
really boring family holidays it would
be raining and we someone would have an
argument and we started creating those
its characters and improvising in
character and then it seemed funny for
those sort of a nerdy polite British
stereotypes to have a dog undercurrent
and you know seething boiling rage
within them just under the surface so we
did that as stage as stage acts because
we're both comedians and then we took it
to TV developed a taster TV channels
from rejected it for big to dark so I
sent it to Edgar Wright and he said I
think there's a film in this I think you
should take it to naira Park and so we
started developing it as a feature with
big talk and with film for as well quite
an interesting journey they go on it's a
favor leads and you said that there was
quite an improv that you were doing as
well to get the characters there how
much of it was set in stone when you
went on set to shoot and how much of
were you in propping with Steve and well
you have your script which works and all
machinery all the cogs are there and
it's all
cents and one of Ben's methods is to you
take a scene and you do the scripture
then you go off script do the same thing
that's in the scene and then you go back
to the script and so really the film is
a mixture you know there are some scenes
that completely new as well because ven
likes to sort of do scenes that are
before after important events to see
what you get from it so the the
beginning in the mother's house there
were scenes there that were completely
improvised and then there are other bits
that move the plot forward that really
had to be very specifically scripted or
it wouldn't work so a real mixture
really but we had hundreds and hundreds
of hours worth of footage to choose from
so Ben had to literally go go through
that and sort of hew a film out of all
this rough material which he saw saliyah
genius at doing so and he mentioned ben
wheatley their course directed kill list
what was it like what people working
with him as director amazing I mean it's
the funnest experience you could have as
an actor I think because you know he he
lets it improvise for a start and you
are improvising from dusk till dawn you
don't sit down you don't rest you're
just in character which for me is
brilliant I love that
and you know he gives you a lot of trust
a lot of freedom to improvise and also
to be truly naturalistic I think you
know he rarely sort of says I didn't
like that act that better because he
actually wants realism and he you know
he will go for the emotion that's coming
out of you but he'll do his best to
create the atmosphere so that you
actually feel like it is happening as
much as possible we actually did shoot
chronologically pretty much which is an
actor is such a luxury and like
privileged to be able to work in that
way and also Ben's just really funny
also it's just it's just great to work
with and also you don't quite know what
to expect from the Edit you know it
could could be three different films
that you see from one cut to the next
because there's so much footage and he
really is sort of painting a picture
with with with the material it does feel
so naturalistic and so real the film as
you say and I wonder if there
kind of things or people that you were
drawing on when you're playing your
character although it kind of horrifies
we think it might be the case well all
my relatives on my dad cider from the
Midlands so definitely I'm exaggerating
my own Midlands accent to play Tina but
I think you know I'm drawing on sort of
family relationships really and the way
that I've seen my own parents bicker
while they've been on holiday or you
know that the power struggle that you
get between a couple which is definitely
drawing on on possible scree my own
relationship you know and definitely the
the characters we went on a camping trip
Steve and I in a caravan for a week and
we took a cameraman with us he filmed us
and so a lot of the tensions are genuine
tensions that come from the dynamic
between me and Steve so that you know it
is actually coming from a sort of
exaggerated version of ourselves or a
parallel version of ourselves rather you
know if I if I stay difficut home in the
Midlands with my mum I think I might be
a slightly different person but a
version of myself what's next for you
now Alice and I've written another
feature which I'm developing hopefully
in partnership with Ron for again it's a
hybrid genre sort of tragedy comedy
horror fantasy it's got a little bit of
everything in it but I'm telling people
it's Madame Bovary meets Trainspotting
to give you some context but it's it's
modern but with it's sort of fantastical
edge
you